.
THEY'RE ALREADY MORE THAN 130
CASES AMONG PARALYMPIC
ATHLETES.
AND IN AUSTRALIA, NEW SOUTH
WALES, JUST REPORTED IN ANOTHER
800 NEW CASES, A SLIGHT DROP
FROM SUNDAY'S RECORD DAILY
HIGH.
MEANTIME, THE PRIME MINISTER
SAYS STRICT COVID MEASURES WILL
COME TO AN END ONCE THE
VACCINATION RATE HITS 70%.
IT COMES AFTER POLICE ARRESTED
HUNDREDS OF ANTI LOCKDOWN
PROTESTERS OVER THE WEEKEND.
ANGUS WATSON IS IN SYDNEY.
ANGUS HIGH, WHAT'S THE
SITUATION RIGHT NOW?
CERTAINLY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
PRETTY ANGRY ABOUT THE WAY
THEY'RE GOVERNMENT HAS DEALT
WITH THIS, AND IT'S BEEN VERY
MUCH FELT IN THE STREETS.
>> ABSOLUTELY ROBIN, THE SCENES
OVER THE WEEKEND IN WHICH
VIOLENT PROTESTERS TURNED OUT
ACROSS AUSTRALIA'S MAJOR CITIES
OF SYDNEY AND MELBOURNE ARE NOT
WHAT MANY PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY WANTED TO SEE AND
ABSOLUTELY NOT POLITICIANS
WANTED TO SEE, THE POLITICIANS
THAT HAVE BEEN TELLING THEIR
CITIZENS TO STAY AT HOME ACROSS
MAJOR CITIES IN SYDNEY AND THE
CAPITOL CAMERA AND MELBOURNE,
AND MELBOURNE PARTICULARLY
VIOLENT SCENE SATURDAY.
THAT'S JUST THE BEGINNING OF
SCOTT MORRISON'S TROUBLES.
THE PRIME MINISTER OF
AUSTRALIA.
HE WAS LAUDED FOR HIS SUCCESS
IN 2020 WITH KEEPING THE VIRUS
AT BAY WITH STRICT LOCKDOWNS
AND STRICT BORDER MEASURES,
KEEPING THE VIRUS OUT.
THE DELTA HAS CHANGED THE GAME
FOR HIM MEANING THAT CASE
NUMBERS MAY BE OUT OF CONTROL.
THEY MAY NOT BE GETTING DOWN TO
LOW NUMBERS THAT WE SAW EARLY
THIS YEAR AND LAST YEAR.
ROBIN, INSTEAD HE WANTS THE
FOCUS TO SHIFT TO
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS OF COURSE
THAT AUSTRALIA'S VACCINATION
RATES ARE TOO SLOW.
JUST OVER 20% OF THE POPULATION
HERE IN AUSTRALIA HAS BEEN
VACCINATED.
SCOTT MORRISON WAS TO BECOME
LOCKDOWNS TO BECOME --
UNTIL 70 TO 80% OF ADULTS HERE
IN AUSTRALIA ARE FULLY
VACCINATED ROBIN?
>> AND TO NEW ZEALAND, A
NATIONWIDE LOCKDOWN UNTIL
TUESDAY I UNDERSTAND.
HOW LIKELY IS THAT THEY WILL BE
RELEASED FROM THAT?
>> ROBIN, JUST MOMENTS AGO THE
PRIME MINISTER OF NEW ZEALAND
AS STOOD UP IN WELLINGTON AND
SAID THAT THE LOCKDOWN WILL
CONTINUE UNTIL AT LEAST FRIDAY.
NEW ZEALAND HAS OVER 100 ACTIVE
CASES OF COVID-19 IN THE
COMMUNITY AT THE MOMENT.
THEY WERE WILLING TO GO INTO
LOCKDOWN WITH JUST ONE CASE
LAST WEEK SO THAT LOCKDOWN
COULD BE EXTENDED EVEN FURTHER
FROM FRIDAY IF NEW ZEALAND
CAN'T GET THOSE NUMBERS OUT OF
CONTROL.
AND THE COVID-19 MINISTER IN
CHARGE, CHRIS HIGGINS SAID THAT
THE DELTA VARIANT AS CHANGED
THE GAME IN NEW ZEALAND AS WELL
AS IT HAS IN AUSTRALIA.
NEW ZEALAND THE COUNTRY THAT
HAS DONE PARTICULARLY WELL AND
KEEPING THE VIRUS OUT.
JUST 26 PEOPLE HAVE DIED IN NEW
ZEALAND THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PANDEMIC.
DELTA IS CHANGING THE GAME, NEW
ZEALAND WANTS TO KEEP ITS
BORDERS CLOSED UNTIL THE END OF
THE BORDER TO GIVE ITS PEOPLE A
CHANCE TO GET VACCINATED.
ROBIN WILL SEE WITH SUCCESS
THEY HAVE IN THE COMING WEEKS.
>> ANGUS WATSON, THANKS FOR
THAT, LIVE IN SYDNEY.
WELL LET'S STICK IN AUSTRALIA.
LIKE TO BRING IN AN INFECTIOUS
DISEASE SPECIALIST, AND
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR AT THE
AUSTRALIAN NATIONAL UNIVERSITY
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
DOCTOR HIGH, LOVELY TO SEE A.
YOU'RE JOINING ME FROM
CANBERRA.
IS THE PRIME MINISTER
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE
RESTRICTIONS IN AUSTRALIA ARE
PERHAPS OVERKILL, TOO TOUGH NOT
EFFECTIVE?
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT
ROBIN.
WE CERTAINLY ARE TRYING TO FIND
THAT FINE BALANCE, WITH TRYING
TO GET LIFE TO MOVE ON NORMALLY
WITHOUT ALL THE ECONOMIC AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND MEDICAL
HARDSHIPS WE HAVE SEEN WITH
COVID, BUT ALSO BALANCING THAT
BY MAKING SURE THAT THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM DOESN'T GET
OVERWHELMED.
SO A LOT OF THE COUNTRY IS IN
LOCKDOWN AT THE MOMENT, IN FACT
WHERE I AM IN CANBERRA IS IN
LOCKDOWN.
>> MANY AUSTRALIANS SEEM TO
THINK THAT THESE LOCKDOWNS ARE
NEVER ENDING.
HAS THE AUSTRALIAN LEADERSHIP
DO YOU THINK BEING BEATEN BY
THIS VIRUS AND TRYING TO
RETREAT INTO AN ISLAND NATION
MENTALITY, WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME NOT TRYING TO DEAL WITH IT
WHEN DELTA SHOWED UP.
HOW MUCH IS DELTA CHANGED THE
CONVERSATION FOR AUSTRALIANS?
>> ROBIN, DELTA HAS BEEN THE
GAME-CHANGER.
WE HAD THE ALPHA VARIANT IN THE
COUNTRY AT THE END OF LAST YEAR,
AND THE START OF THIS YEAR, AND
WE HAD A NUMBER OF INCURSIONS
INTO THE COMMUNITY IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
WE WERE ALL VERY WORRIED
BECAUSE WE KNEW HE WAS MORE
INFECTIOUS THAN THE ORIGINAL
WUHAN STRAIN, BUT NONETHELESS
WE WERE ABLE TO GET ON TOP OF
IT, BUT DELTA IS DIFFERENT.
IT IS FAR MORE INFECTIOUS AND
ONCE IT GETS A FOOTHOLD IN A
COMMUNITY, IT IS SPREADING LIKE
WILDFIRE.
EVEN THE VACCINATION RATES IN
AUSTRALIA HAS JUST ACCELERATED
IN RESPONSE TO SEEING WITH
DELTA CAN DO.
>> WHY IS THE VACCINATION RATE
SO LOW?
AGAIN, IS THIS ANOTHER FAILURE
BY THE GOVERNMENT?
>> SO AGAIN, VERY INTERESTING
LEE ROBIN, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
--
IT SEEMS TO BE A TALE OF ALMOST
2 HALVES.
IF YOU LOOK AT COUNTRIES THAT
CONTROLLED COVID REALLY WELL
THROUGH LAST YEAR, TAIWAN, NEW
ZEALAND, AUSTRALIA, SOUTH KOREA,
AND YOU LOOK NOW, THEY'VE GOT
RELATIVELY SLOW VACCINE
ROLLOUTS.
THAT'S CONTRAST TO COUNTRIES
THAT REALLY STRUGGLED WITH
COVID, LIKE THE U.S., AND UK
WHO'VE DONE VERY WELL WITH
THEIR VACCINE.
I THINK YOU CAN SEE IN
AUSTRALIA BY THE SURGE IN
VACCINATION IN RESPONSE TO THE
LOCKDOWN AND THE DELTA
OUTBREAKS THAT SEEING WHAT
DELTA CAN DO, WHATEVER PART OF
THE WORLD YOU ARE IN WILL EXCEL
OR 8 THE VACCINE ROLLOUT.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
>> FOR MANY AUSTRALIANS, HAVING
THIS NUMBER OF 70% TO 80%
VACCINATED, IT'S KIND OF GOING
TO BE A MOVING TARGET ISN'T IT?
PARTICULARLY IF BOOSTERS COME
INTO PLAY, BECAUSE YOU'RE NEVER
REALLY GONNA GET ON TOP BY
HITTING A 70% BECAUSE YOU'RE
HAVING TO PLAY WITH CATCH UP
WITH WHOEVER GETS VACCINATED
AND NEEDS A BOOSTER IN 8 MONTHS,
PARTICULARLY THE FACT THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE, 20% PERHAPS OF
THE POPULATION AND CERTAIN
TEENAGERS REALLY MAKE UP THAT
DENT INTO 70%.
SO THE NUMBERS WILL NEVER
REALLY ADD UP, AND THAT MEANS
FOR MANY AUSTRALIANS IT'S
ENDLESS?
>> I THINK NOT JUST FOR
AUSTRALIANS, I THINK AROUND THE
WORLD, VACCINATION IS WONDERFUL,
IT'S AMAZING THAT WE HAVE IT --
>> BUT FOR AUSTRALIANS PUTTING
A 70% FINITE NUMBER ON THIS,
YOU'LL NEVER BE ABLE TO GET THE
PIN IT DOWN BECAUSE THE
VACCINATIONS WANE IN EFFICACY,
SO YOU'LL NEVER BE A LOVE A
FINITE, OKAY EVERYBODY'S 70%
VACCINATED, BECAUSE YOU'RE
GONNA NEED BOOSTERS FOR PEOPLE
WHO GOT VACCINATED'S 8 MONTHS
AGO?
>> YOU'RE QUITE RIGHT, THAT'S
WHAT I WAS SAYING, IT'S
WONDERFUL AS WONDERFUL AS THE
VACCINES ARE, AND DELTA BEING
SO INFECTIOUS, WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO ACHIEVE HERD IMMUNITY.
SO WE'RE GONNA TRY TO VACCINATE
AS MUCH OF THE POPULATION AS
MUCH AS WE CAN, CATCHING UP
WITH BOOSTER DOSES AND WORKING
AROUND THAT.
ALL OF THOSE COVID SAFE
MEASURES WE'VE BEEN SEEING
AROUND THE WORLD, SOCIAL
DISTANCING, WEARING MASKS,
THOSE THINGS ARE HERE TO STAY,
SO WON'T BE A COMPLETELY NORMAL
LIFE OR ODDS QUITE A WHILE
ROBIN.
>> AND FOR MANY AUSTRALIANS
SPEAK TO YOU, HOW ANGRY ARE THE?
WE'VE SEEN THEM ON THE WEEKEND
OVER THE STREETS.
BUT IN TERMS OF ORDINARY PEOPLE
WHO ARE LOCKED IN THEIR HOUSES
AND POLICE ARE CHASING THEM ON
THE BEACH, THERE'S BEEN A
PRETTY TOUGH LOCKDOWN IN TERMS
OF CONSEQUENCES.
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND THE
BROADER IMPLICATIONS FOR
SOCIETY.
AND NOT BEING ABLE TO LEAVE.
A STRING IS NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET IN.
HOW DAMAGING IS THIS?
WELL OF COURSE THERE ARE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES.
YOU DO SEE THIS MANIFESTING A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE UNDERSTANDING
AND COMPLIANT, BUT THE PROBLEM
IS BECAUSE DELTA IS SO
INFECTIOUS ANY NONCOMPLIANCE IS
SO UNFORGIVING, BUT YOU ARE
RIGHT ROBIN I, THINK WE WILL
ALL BREATHE A SIGH OF RELIEF
WHEN WE COME OUT OF THIS
LOCKDOWN, BUT IT'S NOT GONNA BE
HERD IMMUNITY, IT'S GONNA BE A
COMBINATION OF GETTING H